peter irgendwann hat dann jemand eine
bierflasche umgestoßen und diese
bierflasche landete genau auf
davos ist herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren chaotischen wie locker diese
teil geht es drunter und drüber bei mir
und ich habe einiges zu erzählen das ist
eine schlimme sache passiert ich glaube
dir zum schluss und ich fange erst ganz
vorne art und zwar hab ich ja gesagt ich
habe jetzt die möglichkeiten neuen pc zu
bekommen ein kollege von mir hat auch
einen alten pc herumstehen derart
irgendwie acht gigabyte arbeitsspeicher
eine 1 gb ati-grafikkarte okay hier
setzt sich das beste auf rang drei zu
glaube ich und nie fünf prozessor muss
ich mal schauen aber dieser pc hat
leider kein betriebssystem hat keinen
bildschirm und keine tastatur das heißt
da muss noch einiges machen bis ich den
benutzen kann und selbst wenn es dann so
weit ist weiß ich nicht ob es
funktioniert da bin ich noch ein
bisschen ratlos
eigentlich hätte auch gedacht dass es
heute eigentlich funktionieren würde
dass ich denn heute bekommen würde aber
dann heute noch mal telefoniert und da
meint sony das und das und das und kein
betriebssystem und dann habe ich mich
natürlich ein bisschen gewundert die
fans ja fast bisschen schade weil liegt
endlich wieder richtig ein bisschen
spielen wenn ich mal ich finde diesen
blogs auch mehr kunden die mache euch
die spaß
ich finde es persönlich extrem cool so
ein bisschen abwechslung zu bringen aber
minecraft habe ich auch mal wieder lust
mal so zu spielen wie aber es ist schon
so lange gespielt
das fehlt einfach irgendwann bricht man
beim eine weile nicht mehr macht na ja
was ich erzählen wollte jetzt haltet
euch fest
gestern abend war hier bei mir zu hause
in der wohnung eine feiern das erzähle
ich euch jetzt unter 2400 augen war es
gestern war hier eine feier und da war
natürlich auch heute meinem zimmer und
ihr wissen in meinem zimmer
das ist übrigens nicht mein thema
sondern erstmal einen mitbewohner
vincent grüßt die winzer das ist ich mag
diesen sessel hier so
so eine coole beinahe plage substanzen
seien teil nicht wegräumt dass er bis
heute hoch so jetzt passt wieder ich bin
hier beim mittel- oder im zimmer und
nehmen dass hier auch vertrat den ort so
cool fand ich hab hier auch seine zimmer
leuchtender softbox und funktioniert
welche bisschen besseres licht hab ich
wollte erst auf dem brocken machen aber
damals so ein schlechtes licht
bei der nordbahn haben das heißt die
sonne scheint jedoch und das nicht
schrecken du musst jetzt nicht weiter
leute und zwar einfach nicht so dass
wieder knapp balkon ist cool deswegen
mag ich jetzt hier
und wie gesagt gestern meine feier und
die leute waren wohl in meinem zimmer
ich habe erst spät davon erfahren dass
überhaupt eine feier ist bei uns es war
glaube ich um halb zwei oder so als
würde ich dann komm mal wieder ich wurde
ja in der wg also einer wohngemeinschaft
zusammen b2 von meinen kollegen hier die
auch an meiner uni studieren in meinem
semester sind
und ja die immer gesagt ja komm mir halt
erst eine feier nicht so ok ich komme ja
aber wie gesagt es sind so viele leute
klar in der eigenen wohnung sagt er ich
bin ich dabei da kommt hier her und dann
sind leute meinem zimmer denk ich mir
okay was machen die da und dann war
erstmal kein problem
wir waren da später irgendwann hat dann
jemand eine bierflasche umgestoßen und
diese bierflasche landete genau auf
meinem laptop das heißt der inhalt das
bier landete auf meinem laptop und zwar
so voll auf die tastatur
und ja das habe ich heute morgen erst
bemerkt wenn morgen aufgewacht
auch mein laptop band und das merke ich
hier über die tastatur
was mache ich als nächstes die tastatur
funktioniert nicht mehr
ja also mein laptop ist jetzt quasi
außer funktion
weil jemand was drüber gestellt wird und
man schöner laptop ich habe keine ahnung
was ich damit machen soll ob ich die
tastatur austauschen kann
wenn ihr es wisst könnt ihr mal in die
kommentare schreiben ich hab gar keine
ahnung
na ja auf jeden fall erstmal sagen was
man lebt er jetzt ein bisschen
ramponiert ist hoffentlich geht alles
klar mit dem neuen desktop wenn das
funktioniert dann brauche ich mir erst
mal nicht für youtube nicht für
minecraft und deswegen hoffe ich mal
dass es dass es läuft ich war mir etwas
zu essen ich habe richtig hunger ist
gerade schon sechs oder so halb sechs
herzliche aufnahme und ja ich mache
etwas zu essen
möchtest du dir gefallen hat und ihr
euch freut auf die zukünftigen
entwicklung und mit mit trauert um einen
laptop
dann lassen daumen nach oben da schreibt
in die kommentare was ihr so denkt was
ich machen kann wenn wir die letzte
wille hilfe wenn die laptop tastatur
aufgrund von dem bier schaden kaputt ist
ansonsten will ich sagen wir uns beim
nächsten video wie der haut reiben